-You just spent last weekend --
I have so many questions
about this.
You went to Madison, Wisconsin.
-I did.
-To see a sporting event.
-That's exactly right.
-But the sporting event
is not a sporting event
I've ever seen live.
Will you please explain
what you went and saw?
-I went to the CrossFit Games.
-The CrossFit Games.
-Yeah.
The Reebok CrossFit Games.
-The Reebok Cross--
Now, you did not --
-Does anybody do CrossFit?
[ Cheering ]
-There you go.
-But there's, like,
a hesitation, as if, like --
"Who's gonna be
the first one to go,
"I do it, too!"
-Yeah.
So, now, do you do CrossFit?
-I do.
-You do?
-Yeah.
-But you did not compete.
You just went to watch.
-Watch people work out, man.
-That's really it.
Okay. So, now,
that's interesting
you framed it that way,
because that's how
I would've framed it, and that's
why I wouldn't have gone.
[ Laughter ]
And yet you went.
-I feel I like -- I feel --
I'm surprised by this.
I feel like
that's right up your alley.
-Look, I don't want
to disparage the hard work
that CrossFit people do,
and there are a lot of sports
I watch that I'm sure
other people wouldn't watch.
But this is the sort of the gist
of what you were watching?
-Oh, yeah, for sure.
-So that's a person
hauling weight.
-Yeah. I'm not -- I'm not sure
who that is, actually.
-You don't --
Oh, you know them all?
-Oh, yeah, totally.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, big-time.
-So you're not just like,
"That guy's working out"...
-That's Matt Fraser.
He's the fittest man on Earth.
-He won.
-Yeah.
I got to meet him,
and I was real excited.
[ Laughter ]
-It looks like
he's jump-roping with weights.
-He's doing --
No, no, no.
-Okay.
-No, Seth.
-Again, you're here
to be the expert.
Clarify.
-Yes, please.
He's doing what are called
double-unders.
-Okay.
-Yeah, where you jump rope
but the rope
goes underneath twice.
-Okay. So you have
to jump high enough,
and go fast enough
that you go cwh cwh!
-That's exactly right.
-All right, good.
[ Laughter ]
I mean,
I'm not a fan of CrossFit,
'cause I don't think
I can wrap my head around it.
-I don't know.
I think you could.
-Is this -- I believe this is
the woman who won the event.
-Yeah, that's Tia-Clair Toomey.
-Congratulations to her,
as well.
-She's from Australia.
-She's from Australia?
-Yeah, the Aussies
had a good performance.
-Oh, really? So if you're
in Australia right now,
you have a lot
to be proud about.
-They're freaking out.
-Really?
-I mean, I would think so.
-And now --
-On the female side, they
took first and second place,
and they had third place
on the male side.
This guy Ricky Garard,
who came out of nowhere.
It was very exciting.
He looks like Mad Max.
A young rugby player.
He went crazy this weekend.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-how many competitors were there
over the course of the weekend?
-I think there's 40 on the male
side and 40 on the female side.
-Okay, and that's 80.
How many do you --
-And, also, there's teams, too.
There's teams for, like,
the best gyms,
or the gyms put together
their best teams,
and they make it there.
So there's a tremendous amount
of competitors.
-All right, so it's the day --
It's the morning
of you going to CrossFit.
What time do you get
to the stadium or whatever?
-Oh, early.
-Okay.
And what time do you leave?
-It's a long --
It's a long day.
But, also, it starts on Thursday
and goes through Sunday.
I mean, the amount of volume
that these guys are putting on,
you have no idea.
-The amount of what?
-Volume.
-Yeah, it's a lot --
There's multiple workouts
every day.
-Wow.
That's fantastic that you care.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, again, I'm so --
Again, I really want to stress,
I think for the people
who went there,
like, God love them.
They worked out so hard.
-Here's the best part.
And I include myself
in this group.
As spectators, you go there,
and everybody's really excited.
And this year, it was in Madison
for the first time.
So, it's, like, a college town,
and everybody
who came in was like --
You know,
college is not happening,
so everybody's like,
"CrossFit, let's go!"
So everybody goes
to these events
dressed in their CrossFit gear
as if,
just in case
a workout breaks out,
I'm ready.
-Oh, wow.
-It would be like going to a
football game in shoulder pads.
[ Laughter ]
-The great thing is --
Here's the thing.
Like, when I'm in the gym,
and every now and then,
I'll be doing something,
and there'll be,
like, a dude acro--
like, a creep just staring
at other people working out.
That's what you did
for a weekend.
-No, no, no, no, no.
-You were a guy
watching other people work out.
-It's sports.
-It's not a sport.
You watch people exercise.
You're a weirdo at the gym.
-But --
[ Laughs ]
Those people at the gym are not
exercising competitively.
-Oh, okay.
There you go.
-See now how it makes --
-You won me over.
-Now it makes sense to you.
-How many of the 80 people
that competed could you name?
-More than I care to admit.
-Oh, my God.
That's fantastic.
This movie is fantastic.
You're talking there about how
you got punched in the face.
-Yeah, by Woody Harrelson.
-Woody Harrelson plays your
father-in-law in this film,
or your girlfriend's father.
-My father-in-law to be.
-Father-in-law to be.
-Yes.
-You're a huge
Woody Harrelson fan.
-Yeah,
it was nerve-racking, too.
'Cause, like,
Woody's one of those actors
who are like so unpredictable,
and that's why
we love him as an actor.
-Was he unpredictable
to work with?
-Yeah.
I mean, it's -- You're --
It's...
He's Woody Harrelson.
-Yeah.
-And I came into the movie.
And, like,
my character in the movie
is an outsider
to the Walls family.
It's about Jeannette Walls
and her life,
and it's an extraordinary film.
But as her fiancé, I'm like --
You know, I come from
the Upper East side, New Yorker.
They're, you know, from --
had just moved there
from the Adirondacks,
so it's obviously a clear
difference in lifestyles.
And so I was an outsider
in the film, as my character,
and then, you know, coming in,
here's Woody and Brie,
and I'm, like, coming in to
the last three weeks of filming.
And you're like,
"Hey, man, how you doing?"
And I'm supposed to be
very nervous in these scenes,
and there was
not a lot of acting.
-Right, 'cause you were just
genuinely that nervous.
-Yeah, totally.
-And did he really
punch you in the face?
-No, he did not
punch me in the face.
Although, going into it,
I didn't know how it was
gonna go, and I was willing.
I thought,
"If we're ever gonna do this,
this would be a good opportunity
and worth getting punched
in the face by Woody Harrelson."
-To be able to tell people.
Like,
"What happened to your face?"
You'd go, "Woody Harrelson."
-Yeah, that's right.
And you, like,
look in the movie,
and you go, "See that?
That was real.
He gave me a real shot."
-He's really unpredictable,
and he punched me in the face.
-But, like, it was good.
We were in it.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
Well, congrats on the film.
-Thank you.
-And again, where did you place
this weekend?
I forget.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughing ]
-I placed first.
I placed first.
-You won --
you won the Best Spectator.
-I won best spectator.
Yeah, that's right.
If a workout had broken out,
I was ready.
I was ready,
and I would've placed.
-I want this for you.
Do you think you'll ever compete
at one of these?
-No. I can't tell you
how far away I am...
-Oh, really?
-...from the level
of how fit these guys are.
-Oh, that's a bummer,
because you're very fit,
and that makes me upset
to know how far away I am.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I thought,
if there were 40, then maybe --
Oh, if there were 80,
I'd do it. No.
-It's not even close.
-All right, gotcha.
Well, I still wish that for you.
Thanks so much for being here.
It's great to see you,
as always.
Max Greenfield, everybody!